Hello everybody!
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, wukau!
TENSI and Aakuma, TENSI and Aakuma!
Yay!
Did you guys watch the cover?
Watch the cover.
Green devil.
The ten, ten, ten, ten, goku, goku.
Ten, ten, goku, goku.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Death, death.
Yeah.
Kita?
Mita?
Yeah.
Devish, dev, dev, dev, dev, dev.
Dev, dev.
Devishly cute.
a minkin kitty i can't speak this does not bode well for karaoke
ask us how much we liked it nine but what are you talking about is it the birth birth birth it's hard to hear you over me looping your incredible new cover death death death cover was such a long time coming i started working on on it.
Oh, let me check Discord.
Um.
Uh, back in February.
Started working on, or rather, I started it in February.
And then, I think things, most of it got done April.
But by then, my voice was completely shot.
And so I was like, I'm sorry guys, I have to wait to record and so i couldn't record until like what last month month before last and so i've just been kind of like buzzing this entire time and i'm like just because i love this song Oh, Phoebe just messaged me New cover with Nimmy,
so cute Thank you
Yeah, I was really, really happy I'm really, really happy with how it came out Both the video and us I think it sounds so, so good I'm so happy with it Worth the way Thank you I do They were so awesome.
So thank you, everybody who worked with me.
Hime.
Well, I'm trying to...
I mean, I don't want to miss anybody.
Wait.
Noi and Desi did the illustrations.
And then the live 2D was Hime.
And then Soke did the video.
And then Veshen did the mixing.
So thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And Shina was the project manager.
i don't want to forget i don't want to forget anybody so thank you everybody thank you thank you thank you thank you so please listen to it lots it cost me a pretty penny so listen not that i make money from you watching the video because uh you know covers covers usually get what's the word uh copyright claimed but I want you to just enjoy it animation was great yeah they did such an amazing job of mimicking the original yeah claimed claimed claimed demonetized yeah yeah yeah so I just really wanted to say and I felt Nimi was perfect because the angel is a little bit devilish and the devil is not so devilish.
At the same time, so I felt like it suited us.
And then, of course, stop getting pregnant, of course I have to say death, death, death.
I'm also a ghost.
So I thought it was like the perfect song for the two of us.
Hearing you cover this song as a dream come true.
And then it was a perfect choice as a partner.
Yeah!
So happy I could sing it with her.
So catchy.
It's so, so catchy.
Yeah.
Both you and Nimi did a great job on the cover.
Why are you guys pregnant now, though?
Did the death, death, death not work?
And I'm sorry I've been doing so many karyokies lately.
for my debut well short but I did a little bit of singing on my debut and then I did an unarchived one not so long ago but that was on that was impromptu but I but ever since my voice has gotten mostly better like 99% better it's also good for me to kind of retrain it because I've been I my voice is better but it also is hard for me to reach some notes that I used to be able to reach
practicing again to get there, you know?
A little bit.
So sorry.
I've been doing a lot of karaoke because I am excited.
I can sing again.
Thank you for the super chance, you guys.
Thank you.
A long time dream of mine?
What kind of dream could that be?
Well, I'm so happy.
That is finally out.
Oh!
Ah!
And so, also because of the 400k.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Wow!
Thank you for that!
So many...
Red pink!
The sassiness you sang with?
Perfect homage to the original performance while serving that trademark Minto attitude.
There's never too many Minto Karyokis!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
No such thing is too much Karyokis.
Did you guys have the same thought?
Did you guys have the same exact thought?
Wow, thank you so much for the 50 Gifted Rubber, thank you.
Listen, thank you so much for Aqua Supa.
Thank you guys!
That squeak at the end though.
Originally, I was going to re-record it because I was just like...
Maybe I shouldn't have that voice squeak.
But then I thought it was kind of cute.
It kind of fit.
So I kept it.
I kept it.
Jeff, thank you.
Twas a great cover.
Thank you so much.
Whoa, weird world.
Do you think your karaoke is something to apologize for?
Well, I know it's not everybody's favorite kind of...
I love your singing, also green women in suits.
Yeah!
My steak is too tender, too juicy.
Love the squeak.
Yay!
Yippee!
Nah.
I'm so happy with how it turned out.
Even though it's my own cover, I'm like, yeah, I want to repeat it.
Even though it was my own cover I'm still so like
And then
She I think she sounded So perfect She was worried about her About her singing But to me I thought it sounded So cute Though luckily the song is not It's less It's more kind of like Talk singing than like singing singing So I you know Even if she is a little self-conscious about that i thought it would still fit her very well and i think it did she sounded amazing your voice is beautiful be don't take you you know how sometimes an idol's performance isn't perfect but it's so much better than they don't but stop it stop stop it stop relating it to idols last year sorry for not enough karaoke this year less karaoke sorry for too Did I do that too much?
When did I ask Nimmy to join?
Probably shortly before I asked Aire about it.
Because I really love noise art.
I thought that she would be able to do it well.
Like replicate the original.
So probably around February...
Late January.
January ish when did when did the original come out I don't remember I look it up I look it up
wait I have to turn the music off because it's gonna play there we go um it came out February 4th was the original I hopped on that February 7th I already Okay, so it came out February 4th of this year, and on the 7th, I was like, yeah, I'm going to cover this.
I hopped on that.
I wasted no time.
I was like, Nimi Nightmare, we want to do this cover with me.
And she said, yeah.
And I was like, okay, thank you.
And then I went immediately to Airu.
I was like, hey, do you guys have time to do this project?
They were like, we can probably start in March or April.
They could start in April.
And I was like, okay, sounds good.
That's crazy.
I was super duper like.
Which sucks because if it had come out originally in like May, June when I wanted it to, it would have been.
It would have been like zooming fast.
Curse my voice.
But it's okay.
Never get tired of your karaoke's.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Deserve to be proud, because you sure make us proud.
I don't know how to put stuff on Spotify.
Maybe I can figure it out.
Striking while the iron is still just like lava.
Yeah!
been back at anime north next year i'll try i'll try um i actually wanted to go to anime north this year but um i wasn't sure if i would be in that hell company um the and uh and so i was going through them and they were like oh no we can't do it so makes me really sad
new cover is good and today's my birthday happy birthday yes again happy birthday happy happy birthday
yeah so hopefully next year hopefully next year Hell company.
Ha da.
Ha da da.
Oh, wait, I'm gonna have to turn off the dono sounds.
I apologize.
I forgot to do them during...
I forgot to turn it off during the...
An archival one.
But thank you!
My favorite part was actually the gift preview you used this morning.
Me too!
I love that part.
Koko-tzuki-nai, hat-nai, moon-nai.
love that part it's fun to say too the song itself is tricky but because it's like sing songy talky so part of it kind of was just us like just kind of saying it how we felt it yeah 10 hey thank you it's nice of you to release your cover up for my birthday birthday to my book happy birthday I'll only be able to to my birthday karaoke sporadically while driving home and fighting traffic.
Oh, drive home safe!
Yeah, the intonations and stuff.
But I think that also makes it kind of our own as well, if it's not exactly to the original, but close enough.
I think it worked.
Yes.
Guys, we only have about one month left of summer.
Isn't that crazy?
Summer, wait, maybe I should get more summer.
Maybe I should be more summery then.
But we're outside.
It's hot.
I'm gonna be sweaty if I don't take off my jacket.
Too fast.
Right.
Doesn't feel like it.
Is this gonna be archived?
It will be archived.
Yes, this will be an archived stream.
But don't leave.
Don't leave, though.
She eats s'mores yet?
I should.
I really haven't done anything summery this whole summer.
But.
That's okay.
I've been having fun, so.
You know.
Archives, I am out of here.
No!
Have you eaten ice cream?
Yeah?
Yeah.
What other summer things have I done?
Bra-funds?
Do you think I need a bra?
What will it support?
The beach?
Well, I went to Enoshima.
I guess.
That's kind of summer-y.
I could go anytime.
But it is a beach-ish.
I didn't walk in the sand.
I touched the sand a little.
But not with my toes.
Barbecue?
Wait!
I did do barbecue!
I did!
That was early summer, though.
Hmm.
Did you eat watermelon?
No.
But I've been craving watermelon recently.
I think I'll grab some.
I want to...
Have you guys ever done the watermelon smash?
With the...
You take the bat and you smash the watermelon?
I've done that before.
It's actually quite effective.
Why did I say it like a...
Like a finisher.
Like a finishing move.
The watermelon smash.
With your thighs.
I think it would go through my thighs.
I think I would need like a ton of spiritual energy to like be super physical form so that I could properly squash it with my thighs.
I don't know if I could though.
My thighs are more squishy than strong.
Maybe.
I don't want to think about it.
I volunteer.
As what?
Shall we sing?
Watermelon rubber band stream.
I've always kind of wanted to try that.
Congrats on the cover.
Thank you.
What should we sing first?
Summer songs.
I so good here.
It's a three-person song, though.
I secordium, secordium.
Are we doing EN or JP or both?
Well...
I didn't set up my switch.
It's probably gonna be okay.
Probably okay.
Hot to go!
That's a fun one to start with.
Hmm.
Let's just...
I could be the one or your new addiction It's all in my head, but I want nonfiction I don't want this world, but I'll take this city Who can blame a girl call me hot, not pretty?
Baby, do you like this beat?
I made it so you dance with me It's like 199 degrees When you're doing it with me Doing it with me.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands now body roll Dance it out, your heart to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands now body roll H-O-T-T-O-G-O H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go Well,
I will alone staring at my ceiling I try not to care but it hurts my feelings you don't have to stare come here get with it no one touched me there in a damn hot minute baby don't you like this beat I made it so you'd sleep with me it's like 199 degrees when you're doing it with me doing it with me H-O-T-T-O-G-O snapping clapping touch your toes Raise your hands on body roll Dance it out,
you're hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your hands on body roll H-O-T-T-O-G-O H-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go What's it take to get your number, what's it take to bring you home?
Hurry up, it's time to supper I'm hard to go Want to take you to your number Hurry up, it's getting cold Hurry up, it's time for supper Order up, I'm hard to go
Hard to go
H-O-T-T-O-G-O H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go It's hot in here!
Is anyone else hot?
I think of that song is so silly.
A hot to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O Hardware store!
I didn't learn it.
I didn't learn the hardware store.
Why you, why you, wow, that would be fun to sing.
wait now i think about it though i don't have a karaoke of yawa wait maybe because um it was a live band so i'm like wait i don't think i have a karaoke of yawa yawa hold on
let me try it was a live band so uh Oh, um, hmm.
Sing some green day.
It's my 20th birthday.
Can you please sing Fantasy by Meiko Nakahara?
If you know, I don't know it, but let me write it down.
I have a list of...
Though I haven't gone through it very much lately.
Fantasy by Meiko Nakahara.
so I can learn it for a future.
Happy birthday, James!
Hold on, give me guys one second.
To set up my Switch.
Hora game.
I learned something yesterday.
I learned that Souls-like games in Japanese are called Parigay.
Parigay.
Because they're Perry games.
Isn't that kind of cute?
Um, kyoko sagas, kiwado.
Parry games.
Parry game.
Interesting.
Yeah, it's kind of cute.
So, so, so, so.
Parry, parry game.
Like, parry.
I love singing this song.
Wow.
I hope they have it.
Yeah.
They should, though, because it was an anime ending.
Why, yeah, why, yeah, why?
It sounds kind of like a baby when I say it like that.
Oh, I forgot to turn off the note of sounds.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Oh, but thank you so much for the don't know.
Thank you.
Yeah, stream labs.
Furry game.
No.
Oh, I was also something.
There was something about furries, too, that I was watching.
the other day too.
There's this guy on TikTok that like, hold on, let me get his name.
Wait, where's my phone?
Oh, there it is.
I left it on the ground.
Okay.
There's this guy on TikTok I like to watch.
I was doing P-Cross on the ground.
But he's actually so interesting.
He like teaches kind of obscure and like obscure japanese and like internet slang and stuff like that it feels very like nico nico doga esk but his name is dr west robertson he's just some white dude that like teaches you about and the video i watched was was video game vocabulary so i recommend him because his stuff is really interesting that guy's cool yeah he's cool i like his stuff you've seen him He's everywhere,
really?
I've never heard of him before.
Am I the only one?
I think I have enough money.
I think actually I still have all the money that you guys...
The e-shop stuff, long, long time ago, you guys gifted some of you guys.
And so I've been using that.
But I wasted it last time.
because it was like a hold on you might see my Elgato go away because I was so scuffed last time of during my debut apologize open source new window there we go okay and then let me get it not 90 days three hours three hours three 300 yen.
Cover your Elgato girl.
And then...
Yeah, I still have like 6,000 yen.
It's crazy.
Yes, you are, Kat.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's right?
Yeah.
Oh, it wasn't even going...
I thought the karaoke was going to start.
I'll adjust the sound as it starts and stuff.
It'll start in a second.
I started to look like a little bit like this.
It's just so weird and I'm alone, I get to go go.
And all these words, all these words, all these things are all special, they're all colored to me.
Papa, today, from the morning to the night, even if I think about you all right now, Oh, how do you get there?
This love is going to be the love This chig-hagg, I'll stop it P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-P-I This is love,
love, love, love No, mama, jam, oh
It's kind of a bit too much, This kind of a long time, I'm sure I'm probably the right way to go, I'm not too much, I'm not too much
Nana no, you can't do it.
Hehehe.
Fully-zumote ku.
Kimi-e no, Kimi-e no, awa-tadashi-ku no, new, new, today, today, today, today,
Sorry, I forgot the middle.
That was waya waya waya waya waya, which is not really a summer song at all because the show takes place in Hokkaido.
It was so cold the whole time.
Also, the music was like so low for me.
I had to keep turning it up.
Hold on, let me adjust my El Gato stuff.
Maybe like the...
Cold places have summer too?
No, I guess so.
Sounded fine on your end?
Okay, that's good.
I'm gonna go to the songs and search summer.
Actually, wait, maybe there's like some...
Uh...
Anime...
What's your anime?
Nostalgic Vocaloid.
Let's see what we have here.
What did...
Next page?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, they do have ice cream.
I don't...
I could try.
I don't remember... I only remember the chorus.
I don't remember how the verses go.
Actually, I've been listening to the...
Koyori from Hello Live.
released a cover recently and I've been listening to her I've been listening to her cover there is a Chiyage Hanabi but I don't know the rapping part I don't know Yonazu Kenji part at all
What is that from?
From the first time in forever.
What's it from?
What?
Wait, sabi kara?
Wait.
Sabi?
Just the chorus?
Hold on, let me see what this is.
No way.
Wait, this is so funny.
Hold on, just so you guys know I'm not bullshitting.
Oh, from frozen!
Oh, sabi kara.
No way, is it just that part?
Choco mint!
Your
strawberry flavor Yorima-anata!
Shiki-chan!
Hi!
What do you like?
Cookie and cream?
Yorima-anata!
Mina!
Hi!
What do you like?
Of course!
I love ice cream!
Nobody
else knows this song.
They had to add literally just the chorus to karaoke for people to do.
That's insane.
I scream chorus only.
That's so funny.
I didn't even know there was more.
Oh, I forgot to turn off the streamlapse.
Sorry, I keep...
I'm all over the place.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry I'm all over.
Save.
Ah!
So I have to go to each individual sound and turn them to zero.
She's our pro streamer.
Na na na na na na na.
You guys can see what else there is.
Let's see.
Where do my...
There it is.
I can't watch the preview, though, because the timing is so bad.
Wait, anime, yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
What would it be?
Summer, summer.
Love the song cover with Nimi.
Congrats.
Thank you, guys.
Make sure you loop, loop, loop it.
Loop and listen much.
I wanted to, I meant to ask Vesan if they could do a mix that had only Nimi, but me out so that I could sing it.
So that I could sing it, but I forgot to ask.
I'm sorry.
It's very loopable.
Yippee!
Butterfly is always fun.
We are...
Peace sign.
Oh my gosh.
During Liz's 3D, and she sang that, the Hero 2, I was so... I love that song for her.
my hero so i was so like i was so emoy new brain rot and watch it too you can oh my gosh cough we sung at the same stage isn't that crazy we sung on the same stage oh my gosh and we did this mean doky doby sugar song and butter stuff
yeah but there i don't know version without without jonesu kenji wait this is this is summer song for real i actually have a cover of this song but long long long ago
long long long Long, long ago, let's not look at the music video.
I'll laugh.
Okay.
Can
I shaft tilt?
What
happened to me?
And everyone said it and laughed Atari-mo-nigh My way My way Like a maca-mighty-ne-ha-shy And I walked away With all my feelings But I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry But I'm afraid I'm afraid I'm afraid I'm The night sky is a star, The stars are full of stars It's from you,
It's from you.
I'm the one who's been there.
Please, please don't be surprised.
Don't be surprised, Tell me, tell me, my heart, my heart, my heart.
Arregatenev, Artelevega, You are your hands on the third, I remember you, I'm looking for you.
I finally found you, the ory-hime-same, But where's the other one?
The little bosh-sama This is a one-touch A-touch It's a fun-giant one one-touching One I can't say anything but I'm always First of all, I knew about you.
Where did you find me?
I found my hand, but it won't be able to reach me.
It's no, it's not.
Don't cry, don't cry.
So I said, Ah, I'm a strong, I was a little bit I'm not interested in but But, But the heart of the heart The heart of my heart Is, oh, yeah, What do you mean?
What do you want to say?
The heart's voice will hear You're the one who's next to you The truth is sad-cooked I didn't say it, I didn't say it again I'm not going to be able to see that that's all that's all that's all that's all that's all I loved it.
It's a bit strange, isn't it?
I know it was just that you don't know it's just a little bit of my own secret.
It's a night that's all over the place in a long way.
It's like you are the only one who's the only one who's the only one.
I know what song I want to sing next
Don't worry, we can switch back and forward But right now I'm just thinking Nihongo only But I won't sing only Nihongo I will sing lots of stuff Oh my gosh, that song is so hard.
I could try.
I'll sing that one before I try singing.
Umah.
The song, I can't sing it.
I'll just tell you now.
I'll just tell you now I can't sing Umah Pure Identity because it's so hard.
I kind of know it.
Barely.
Rake it off.
I gotta learn it better.
Wait.
Okay, I know the chorus of this song.
But I don't know.
This song is so hard.
Wait, isn't there an English version of this song now?
I wonder if I could sing that.
The first 33% is really hard.
I know.
I can't do it.
I'm just gonna be like...
Ichi-Ni-Tu-Tu-Tu-Tu?
Yo-I-O!
Oh, my pioi!
Fight!
Daichi-Li-Li-Di-Li-Li-Li-Li-Li-Li-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-Di-DiDiDi-DiDiDi-DiDiDiDiDiDi-DiDiDiDi-DiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDiDi
I don't know this part either Wait, the music video is kind of Oh, we missed the guy skiing Or snowboarding Oh, wow Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Wait, I've lost it.
Look at him go.
Look at him go!
I don't know the rest.
I'm gonna quit it here.
I'm gonna quit while I'm ahead.
Yeah!
That was kind of umapyo-yoi- umap-umap- that was kind of umapyo-yoi-den-setsu.
Okay, next the total tonal whiplash, I apologize in advance.
Tonal- oh, what did I just move?
Tonal whiplash.
Covered chocolate by Babymetal.
Yude-pioi-denetsu.
Yeah!
The favorite mumble rubber.
Oh, wait.
Oh, uh...
Stop, you flatter me.
Stop!
There she is.
Then maybe after the song we'll go back to...
Ego!
Which one should I do?
Actually, can I do all three?
I really like this artist, but I always sing the same three songs, because they're my favorite.
Oh my gosh, they have a sabi-cara too.
Sabi, sabi, S-A-B-I.
In Japanese, it's chorus.
So sabi-cara is chorus karaoke for people that only know the chorus.
And they have sabi-cara of this too.
That's so funny.
Yeah.
Bekizune.
I could try.
Let me do two of these.
I'll do this, y'all.
Because we have a hana bee behind me.
I know, but still want to be close to you.
I know,
I know.
In the summer, in the rain and the rain, the pothapotha, falling down, the green-gown annavy, with the light, the eyes are glaring, and in the instant I'm going to see the moon.
The moon of the moon, the
moon and the moon is iniquity, and it's not going to be this summer's only life and I'm going to make it a little bit of time just for your happiness I'm going to see you.
The night of the night is bright.
The night of the snowy night is falling.
The golden flowers are made out of the blue sky.
No one can say any words.
The moment you make your smile.
Nats no Nats no no no In the
Nats no no Nats no no In the rain Pota Pota Foggy
Hickory Netsune I'm sure You'll have your You can't hear me.
The night of the night is full of night.
The boda boda is falling, kinkyo, and the flowering.
No words can't speak any words.
The moment you can't hear me.
You can't
hear me.
Yuppie!
Ene!
Thank you.
I want to sing.
Sorry.
Oi.
Do I have to put in her name?
Do I have to put in her name again?
I'm lazy.
Z-R.
Thank you for Summer Song!
Yeah!
Next one is from a movie that I really like which movie oh it's kind of sad oh no you're not lazy not what was it uh oh wait it's written right there there's a movie but it's really cute but it's sad but it's cute but it's sad
Puggy Puggy!
Good morning.
It's about this girl who does photography but she's really nerdy and this guy who like...
She's normal.
I clicked
mute instead of reverb.
But
he's kind of a jerk to her because she's a little nerdy, but she's so cute.
She's just quirky.
But then it's sad, a sad movie, if you watch.
I'm more than ever.
Miserie Miserie Miserie Miserie Miserie I've seen a lois
I'm a Don't know and all the time, all the time to be I'm just I love you and my heart was just I love
love I love I love you.
I love you.
Just that's it.
It's just that it's good.
When the rain when it's raining, the I've seen the kiss is it's the two two two two two is all all are all I can't but you
Sorry, there's like no foodie gana and some of the kanji and I go like, I'm like a kindergartner, please I'm reliant.
I can't, I can't read it, but I can.
I'm so sorry.
No, the music video, baby, love.
I think she was confessing her feelings to him, but she just gives him this joy.
Oh Sorry, I didn't look too
I'm so sorry I need to turn these off
You.
Futari.
Sorry.
Her and her West Virginia hat.
Oh, I'm...
I was okay until she just handed him a rolled up piece of paper.
I was okay.
Okay, girl who left her time.
That's a great idea.
Oh golly, I'm so sorry everybody.
It's fine, this is karaoke.
I've sung that song before.
Probably better than this.
No, no, no, no, that's a Rennai Shashen.
Rennai Shashen.
Holy moly.
Okay, I won't pay attention.
I was really good at ignoring it until just there.
Oh man, I suck.
Okay, wait.
If I search Tokyo Kakeh Ujo, will it show up?
Oh, I...
Oh my gosh.
I have to show you guys right now.
I was looking for something in my closet.
And I...
Hold on, I'm taking a picture right now.
I'll show you literally in this very moment.
I was looking for something in my closet.
And I was going through like old drawers.
And I found this.
And I was like, oh my gosh, I forgot I had this.
I've never used it before.
It's like pristine.
It looks kind of goofy.
as it is, but it's...
Wait, let me make it smaller.
Let me make it smaller.
One moment.
Please hold.
It's related to the Girlhood Up to Time, which is like my favorite movie ever.
Because uh, there was once a a collab cafe when I was living in Japan, there was a collab cafe for an anniversary.
An for the anniversary of of...
not Tokikake, something else.
But they included Tokikake in there.
And...
that's my favorite movie, so I went.
And I was like, Yahoo!
And I bought this there.
I actually still have, like, cups and stuff that I use from the collab cafe.
Uh, here.
Look at my...
Please hold!
Please hold.
Look at my...
My handkerchief!
Which has the two main characters and they're on their little bike.
This is so cute.
If you guys watch the movie, you know.
It's so cute, right?
It's so cute.
And they're like, I love the style, like the way that it's...
That's so cute.
Yeah, watch the movie if you haven't watched it.
It's so good.
It's also pretty sad though.
To-to-to-toke-toke-toke.
Oh, ah, ah, oh, there it is.
I don't know a movie.
The girl who leapt through time!
The girl who leapt through time.
Yeah, we'll do this one.
My mom bought that movie to watch with the whole family because she thought it would be like, Totoro!
Were you guys traumatized by the ending?
Because I would be.
Okay, I'm going to keep the music video up so that you guys, if I...
If I laugh about something, we'll all laugh together, okay?
Hopefully the music video is not stupid.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, we've seen this one before.
This one won't get me, I don't think.
It's a lot of fun for me to get up to you.
I wanted to see all the different faces I wanted to see.
The big eyes, the big, the big, the big, now I'm going to put my head on my head.
I'm a different person in the world I'm I'm
I'm I'm looking for something I'm looking for I'm looking for that day's me, I'm not I'm not I'm trying to get over over my own
He's a cool guy
He's a cool guy But the night was white, you were talking to us.
You said, You said, You said, You said, I said that voice, now it's still sound now even though it's still heard from the voices
I said, I said, I love you and love you.
I was looking for something that I was looking for.
That day I found a place to go to, if you and me together can go there, I'm still alive I'll be back again
I'll be the one I'll be the one I'll be holding I'll be the one The broken sound I can't hear The same way I'm still on the same way The same way I'll trust you to continue.
I'm always looking for the things that you never forget.
I don't want to forget you.
I love you.
I want to see you.
Thank you guys, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Shall we go to some English songs?
Some English, English maybe.
I'll keep the, what's it called?
Joy sound music in the background though.
It's playing a guitar, but I hear a single guitar in the song.
Because it's...
It's...
Can I sing, Leve?
Sing some of the songs that I did not last unarchived.
I'll sing some songs that I did in the last archive.
Yes?
Yes, I love Lever.
Goodbye, Dory Song.
Ciao.
The skyscrapers causing vertigo.
The countdown begins in Tokyo.
27 days alone means 20 million ways to cope.
Without you I'm in a reckless fever Love struck girl, I tease her Thought I'd never be her Quite the job you've done on me, sir You've been hosting parties In my mind, I'm working Over time to have you in my world Oh, what a curse it is to be a lover girl forced to get creative wrote my feelings down the independent lady in me is nowhere to be found I can't wait another day to see you how embarrassing to be this way I'm in a reckless fever left struck girl I tease her never thought I'd be her quite the job you've done on me so you've been hosting parties in my mind I'm working over time to have you in my world oh what a curse it is to be in love I wave by the phone like a high school movie dream
to me think I see you in the wings God I'm hallucinating what a reckless weaver love struck girl I tease her there'd I'd never be her quite the job you've done on me sir you've been hosting parties in my mind I'm working over time you've become my whole world oh what a curse it is to be a lover girl
that was lover girl lie by one other songs that i do on that oh um this one
I made a promise to distance myself Took a flight through Aurora skies Honestly, I didn't think about how we didn't say goodbye just see you very soon it hurts to be something it's worse to be nothing with you so
I didn't call you for 16 long days And I should get a cigarette for so much restraint no matter how long I resist temptation I will always lose.
It hurts to be something, it's worse to be nothing.
with you I've done the math there's no solution will never last why can't I let go of this
so I broke my promise I called you last night I shouldn't have, I wouldn't have If it weren't for the sight of a boy who looked just like you Standing out on Melrose Avenue It hurts to be something, it's worse to be nothing with you
it hurts to be something it's worse to be nothing
with you
not the vacation thank you that was promised by live song that was in a an archived karaoke recently so I figured maybe I should sing them in an archived karaoke apparently I twice in the same Shut up.
Just do the whole album.
I have been listening to a lot of Lifi Lifi recently.
Oh gosh.
What about this one?
Can I remember this one well enough?
Hold on.
Let's see.
Yeah, I think I remember.
Feeling kind of sick tonight All I've had is coffee and leftover pie It's no wonder
Still you take up all my mind I don't even think that you care like I do I should stop, heaven knows I've tried.
One day, I will stop falling in love with you.
Someday, someone will like me.
me like I like you until then I'll drink my coffee eat my pie pretend that we are more than friends then of course I'll let you break my heart again I'm
just trying to understand what I am to you more than songs we've exchanged midnight calls I don't remember this part sunset views
promise I don't mean to cry but I give over overwhelmed and confused if only you you knew what i felt like
one day i will stop falling in love with you
Someone will like me like I like you Until then I'll drink my coffee, eat my pie Pretend that we are more than fruits Then of course I'll let you break my heart again
someday I will stop falling in love with you
Until I do I'll be thinking of you I don't know how this part goes Let you break my heart
again that one was a little scuffed my bad that was let you break my heart again guys I want to sing some Disney what Disney what Disney what Disney just gonna put in Disney Disney oh has the world came Are you guys depressed now?
Hercules!
What Hercules?
Gotta go teach cry punching now.
What does that mean?
The Simpsons theme song.
The Simpsons.
A simple and clean!
I feel like people really like...
Wait, I think a long time ago I sang simple and clean.
To this exact background.
People really like when I sing this song.
I feel like...
People, hold on, I think I need a, let me, let me spray my throat spray.
Poor unfortunate souls.
Because you kill it.
I'm done.
Bye bye from a critically acclaimed live action film, The Lion.
thinking.
What throat spray?
I got this in Japan.
It's called Purple Shot Plus R.
But I don't like it very much because it's rose flavor and I don't like rose flavor anything.
I don't like the smell of roses.
I don't like the taste of roses.
I don't like it.
Before I do Simple and Clean, let me...
No, we'll do Simple and Clean.
It's fine.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say, Please, oh baby, don't go simple and clean Is the way that you're making me feel tonight It's hard to let it go
You're giving me too many things lately, you're all I need.
Oh, you smiled at me and said, don't get me wrong, I love you, but does that mean I have to meet your father when we...
are older you'll understand what i meant when i said no i don't think life is quite that simple when you walk away you don't hear me say please oh baby don't go simple and clean is the way
tonight it's hard to let it go so simple and clean the daily things like this and that and what is what that keep us all busy are confusing me that's when you And said, I wish I could prove I love you, but does that mean I have to walk on water?
When we are older, you'll understand it's enough when I say so.
And maybe some things are that simple.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say, So baby, don't go simple and clean It's the way that you're making me feel tonight It's hard to let it go Hold me, whatever lies beyond this morning Is a little later on, regardless of warnings It doesn't scare me at all Nothing's like before When you walk away You don't hear me say Please Oh baby,
don't go Simple and clean Is the way that you're making me feel Tonight It's hard to let it go Hold me, whatever lies beyond this morning Is a little later on Regardless of warnings, the future doesn't scare me at all Nothing's like before Hold me, whatever lies beyond this morning is a little later on regardless of warnings the future doesn't scare me at all nothing's like before oh oh yeah
oh yeah oh
my gosh that song doesn't allow me to swallow my spit in the middle so I'm like Hold me!
I'm like...
I had to put on my glasses so I'd be less embarrassed.
But I want to sing this one.
Can I sing this one?
I don't remember why I haven't sung this one before.
More Kingdom Hearts.
Let's say English.
Maybe it's kind of cringe.
How did I live in a kingdom of these?
And people who say things they don't really mean, really mean all.
You're only everything I've ever dreamed of.
ever dreamed of, ever dreamed of You must be kidding me, did you really think I could say no?
I want you for a lifetime, so if you're gonna think twice So baby, I don't wanna know, baby, I don't wanna know everything It's just right But if you're gonna think twice So baby, I don't wanna know Baby, I don't wanna know I really don't get What everyone else believes
And so why do I say The things I don't really mean It really means, oh, I'm only crying because I never dreamed It'd take, take this long, it'd take this long I want you for a lifetime, so if you're gonna think twice So baby, I don't wanna know, baby,
I don't wanna know everything is just right And baby, I don't wanna know, baby, I don't wanna know.
Don't think twice.
Don't think twice, baby, don't think twice.
If you wanna take it to an even higher level, all you gotta do is say the word, you know I'll follow.
If you wanna take it to an even higher level, I don't...
If you wanna...
All you gotta do is say the word, the walls will crumble If you wanna make it happen, nothing's impossible Ha!
If you wanna die So if you're gonna think twice So baby, I don't wanna know Baby She talked about biting!
Everything is just right But if you're gonna think twice So baby, I don't wanna know Baby, I don't want to know Kiss me once Kiss me twice I don't think twice I don't know this one Don't think twice Don't think twice, baby Don't think twice Kiss me once Kiss me twice
I don't know how this part goes.
Don't think twice.
Yeah, I'm thinking twice about singing this song, yeah.
Why did she say baby so many times?
it's so different from the japanese even like part of the cadence is different well that was don't think twice i like the japanese one i think i was it's so like i want to sing this song because i like it but i only like the japanese one yeah baby yeah baby baby with justin beaver over here It's such a pretty song,
but the Japanese one is so much nicer.
But the part where it's like the fast part, I can't read it fast enough because I'm stupid.
I'm still here from Treasure Planet.
I don't know.
Torn?
This sounds familiar, but I don't think...
Tangled!
Let's see.
Hmm.
Tangle makes me cry though.
I love Tangled.
Oh, I did do Simple and Clean.
Thank you.
I forgot to write a...
Simple and Clean.
Just a few more songs, guys.
Oh, wait.
It hasn't even been two hours.
That's crazy.
Hmm.
Oh, new world.
I want to sing Disney.
Let me just type in Disney.
Disney.
Oh.
Bye-bye.
There was one song I was listening to that I was like, oh my gosh, I need to sing this karaoke.
But I can't remember what it was.
Hellfire.
It's there?
Oh, yeah.
Bye-bye.
I'm going to make you go.
Wait, actually, is it?
Oh, yeah, there it is.
I was like, I'm pretty sure it's here.
Wait.
Lion King.
That but with passion.
Oh, I love passion.
I actually like both versions of passion, though.
I think the English one is not so bad.
But don't think twice is just...
It's like, it's like, it's like she thought, you know, that's how English people speak.
They're just like, hey baby, hey baby, hey baby, hey baby, hey baby, hey baby, hey baby.
And you and I have a new name.
Uh-oh.
No, they're my.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
My sanctuary.
Wait, I can't even remember what the...
Wait, I can't remember what the I always wanted a breather.
I don't know how that song is called.
What's it called?
What?
I can't remember it at all.
I always wanted a breather.
Just like you.
What was it called?
It's not called Sanctuary.
You guys...
Why are you guys saying sanctuary?
No, we're past that.
No, I'm talking about the brother's song.
You guys are talking about Kingdom Hearts.
We are on two different wavelengths.
You guys are right.
You guys are like, Mint, it's called sanctuary.
No, it's called the Lion King.
I don't I don't see it on here.
Selection work?
It's called I always wanted a brother.
I always wanted a brother.
Wait.
They don't have it!
Unfortunately copyright owners do not authorize the project.
Disney's mad.
Disney's mad at their sound.
They don't...
Oh wait, no, no, no, that's not what I'm saying.
I meant to click, I accidentally clicked this.
Oh, gosh.
Go, go, go.
Okay, never mind.
Just kidding.
You guys didn't even hear it.
Everything's fine.
Hold on.
I saved a song recently that I wanted to sing.
I have to go to TikTok.
I have to go to TikTok and find it.
I'm not singing Sanctuary now out of spite.
Wait, did I save it?
I don't see it.
Unless it got taken down.
I'll cry.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, I think I got taken down.
I saved it like today, so.
My memory is too bad.
Hello?
Oh, oh, oh!
I saw him moving.
Hello?
I'm back.
What the heck just happened?
Oh.
Oh, my stream deck is possessed.
That's what's happening.
Okay, Disney.
Sabrina Carpenter?
There's too many people making a killing out.
So I just wanted a brother, yeah.
Oh, what's Sabrina Carpenter?
I think I only know espresso.
And please, please, please.
Don't move, I'm right.
Espresso.
Okay, I'll do espresso.
Now he's thinking about me every night oh, he's not sweet I guess so Say you can't sleep, baby I know that's that me espresso Move it up, down, not try it all, switch it up like Nintendo Say you can't sleep, baby I know that's that me espresso I can't relate to desperation are on vacation and I got this one boy and he won't stop calling when they act this way I know I got him too bad your ex don't do it for ya walked in and dream came true to for ya soft skin and I perfumed it for ya yes I know I'm mounting do it for ya that morning coffee brewed it for ya one touch and I brand new to for ya He's thinking about me every night,
oh Isn't that sweet, I guess so?
Say you can't sleep, baby, I know That's that me, espresso Move it up, down, left, right, oh Switch it up like Nintendo Say you can't sleep, baby, I know That's that me, espresso Holy shit Is that sweet, I guess so?
I'm working late Cause I'm a streamer Oh, we look so cute Wrapped around my finger My twisted humor Make him laugh so often My honeybee Come and get this fallen Too bad your ex don't do it for ya Walked in and dream came true to for ya Soft skin and eye perfume to for ya I know I'm mountain do it for ya That morning coffee brooded for ya One touch and eye brand new to for ya Think about me every night,
oh, isn't that sweet, I guess so.
Say you can't sleep, baby, I know, that's that me, espresso.
Move it up, down, left, right, oh, switch it up like Nintendo.
Think about me every night, oh, isn't that sweet, I guess so.
Say you can't sleep, baby, I know, that's that me, espresso.
Move it up, down, look right, oh Switch it up like Nintendo Say you can't sleep, baby I know That's that me espresso Isn't that sweet, I guess so
That's that me espresso
The song is so sexy Wow, even though it's about coffee Nintendo Switch.
Es-es- Espresso.
My gay heart can't handle this.
Sabrina Carpenter is so sexy.
She's so sexy.
Tascaru.
Shady, thank you so much for that.
Ah, Kaisalpa, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Which one of us is the ghost?
Oh,
okay, I think I'll do one last song, guys.
One last song.
Oh, no.
Yeah, just one, just one.
Don't want to push it too hard.
thank you so much holographic for the five gifted thank you thank you guys for all the don't knows and for i hope you guys really enjoyed the karaoke and i mean the cover the cover and the karaoke of course um but uh yeah um is i guess it's been a minute since i've done a proper proper karaoke huh what though should i finish with.
Beyond the sea.
Last couple of karaoke streams have been so nostalgic.
Why nostalgic?
Chocominto Ayes has a two-person song.
Thank you.
Thanks for the vibe gifted.
Nahuel.
I hope I said your name right.
Thank you for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
Orca wanted to send Mint Brina Carpenton Bro is very happy So what does that think it's I don't
know Oh gosh Oh Pusigino Karate Always gets my My streams taken down So As much as I would want to Probably can't for that
not snake eater i'll be at mgs con this weekend i'll be thinking of snake eater plenty enough i think and delta is next week so yeah delta's next week hmm evermore someone brought up toradora i like toradora break stuff no no sorry Sorry, sorry.
Oh, why is it so hard for me?
Why is it so hard?
Part of me wants to do a song that I have not done before.
But also, like, maybe something that I haven't sung in a while before.
Let me look up Toradoro.
Come back to me!
Joy-sal!
Ah!
Oh!
Sorry, I dropped my controller.
What are you guys asking for?
Joji!
ViviCorps, thank you, oh, you're Patamon now!
Oh gosh, thank you for the five, give me the...
Can I get the Chobits OP?
Wait, I like that song.
Can you sing the Carl Weezer song?
Okay, I'll do a couple more.
You guys are...
Okay, Toradora, Toradora!
Chobits!
Toradora Chobits!
Carl Wazer.
I've been thinking about this series a lot lately, actually.
Jimmy's, ma'am.
I saw people saying orange.
But I also like...
Oh, wait.
What's the other one?
That's the character song.
You know what?
I'll just...
Then there's my sticky number.
I think I know orange the best, though.
If
It's not true, why?
Why?
The real me?
I don't know.
Just know.
The big, large, big, one, one, one, one, one, a whole bunch of seeds.
The little bit.
me I love orange orange green color me love I
love love love look look
I think this video is Yuri!
Tane more light
Tane and Tsubomi are still I love you Me, the
orange color on that day I remember I remember two of the shadows my
future I didn't want to eat everything I
love but I'm gonna I'm gonna
I love I'm not gonna cry I'm gonna cry Orange in the way, I'm gonna be happy With your light and light And your dreams are full of hope And all you've got to be like that Orange, I've tried to eat it, but But if you're not like me, it's not like you I love you I love you I love you I love you I love you I love you I love you I love you I love you I love you I love you I love you Oh my gosh.
Yuri on the screen!
Let's go.
Suki, die yo.
Ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-bitch.
Choo-choo-choo.
How do I make- Choo- How do I make small?
Choo.
B- Oh yeah, she said zero.
Natsu Matsuri I think For some reason I can't sing Or rather, I can sing that song But I forgot it Last time I tried singing it I remember I forgot it I'm so sorry
I'm so excited to see Yeah,
I'm gonna hug you Yeah, I'm gonna hug you Yeah, I'm gonna
hug you I'm gonna meet you I'm gonna wait for five minutes Wait for the other two
I'm ruining the song, I'm sorry.
What
a romantic story.
Ah-ha.
.
Yeah!
Let me be
with you!
Why did I say it like, what is important to?
What does that mean?
He's like, are you down to do number one or two?
Oh, baseball.
And then they'll get married.
All right, last song.
Last song.
Wait, that was...
Let me be with you.
Look at that song.
one's for you Jimmy's mom Jimmy's mom
I don't want a friend I want my life in you waiting to get there waiting for you when
I'm around so dancing in the dark Don't follow me, I'll end up in my arms You got made up your mind I don't need no more signs Can you?
Can you?
Give me reasons we should be complete You should be with him, I can't compete You looked at me like I was someone Someone else Can't you see me?
I don't wanna slow dance In the dark Dark
Just hear my voice You Shutting me out of you Doing so great You
Used to be the one To hold you I don't know how the spark goes for Yeah, yeah, yeah I don't fuck with your tone I don't wanna go home Can there be one night?
Give me reasons we should be complete You should be with him, I can't compete You looked at me like I was someone else Can't you see?
I don't wanna slow dance In the dark
Sorry I had it before Go listen to
my cover Actually I'll write into it Wait can I write into a song Or into a streamer Can I read into a video?
Wait I don't even know what I'm saying anymore Thanks guys!
Thank you for karaoke I had a lot of fun Wait I don't think I can oh well
thank you we'll listen to the cover anyway thank you everybody wait I can post a link listen listen listen post a link post post post post thank you thank you for the bye bye bye bye